let me ask you about your own personal
psychology a tricky question you've been
known at times to have a bit of an ego
do you think he says who but go on do
you think ego is empowering
or limiting for the task of
understanding the world deeply
I reject the framing
so you disagree with having an ego so
what do you think about it I I think
that the question of like what leads to
making better or worse predictions what
leads to be able being able to pick out
better or worse strategies is not carved
at its joint by talking of ego so it
should not be subjective it should not
be connected to your to the intricacies
of your mind no I'm saying that like if
you go about asking all day long like uh
do I have enough ego do I have too much
of an ego I think you get worse at
making good predictions I think that to
make good predictions you're like how
did I think about this did that work
should I do that again
you don't think we as humans get
invested in an idea and then others
attack
you personally for that idea so you
plant your feet and it starts to be
difficult to when a bunch of
low effort attack your idea to
eventually say you know what I actually
was wrong and and tell them that it's
it's as a human being it becomes
difficult it is it is you know it's so
difficult so like Robin Hansen and I
debated AI systems and I think that the
person who won that debate was guern and
I think that reality was like to the
utkowski like well to the utkowskian
side of the utkowski handsome Spectrum
like further from utkowski
and I think that's because I was like
trying to sound reasonable compared to
Hanson and like saying things that were
defensible and like relative to Hansen's
arguments in reality was like way over
here in Pickler in respect to it's like
Hanson was like all the systems will be
specialized Hanson May disagree with
this characterization Hanson was like
all the systems will be specialized I
was like I think we built like
specialized underlying systems that when
you combine them are good at a wide
range of things and the reality is like
no you just like stack more layers into
a bunch of gradient descent and
I feel looking back that like by trying
to have this reasonable position
contrasted to Hansen's position
I missed the ways that reality could be
like more extreme than my position in
the same direction
so is this like
like is this a failure to have enough
ego is this a failure to like make
myself be independent like I I would say
that this is something like a failure to
consider positions that would sound even
wackier and more extreme when people are
already calling you extreme
but I wouldn't call that not having
enough ego
I would call that like
insufficient ability to just like clear
that all out of your mind
in the context of like debate and
discourse which is already super tricky
in the context of prediction in the
context of modeling reality if you're
thinking of it as a debate you're
already screwing up yeah so is there
some kind of wisdom and insight you can
give to how to clear your mind and think
clearly about the world man this is an
example of like where I wanted to be
able to put people into fmri machines so
then you'd be like okay see that thing
you just did you were rationalizing
right there oh that area of the brain
lit up like you are like now being
socially influenced it's kind of the
dream and you know
I don't know like I want to say like
just introspect but but many for any
people introspection is not that easy
like like notice the internal sensation
can you catch yourself in the very
moment of feeling a sense of well if I
think this thing people will look funny
at me okay and like now that if you can
see that sensation which is step one can
you now
refuse to let it move you or maybe just
make it go away and I feel like I'm
saying like I don't know like somebody's
like how do you draw an owl and I'm
saying like well
just draw an owl
so I I feel like maybe I'm not really
that that I feel like most people like
the advice they need is like well how do
I notice the internal subjective
sensation in the moment that it happens
of fearing to be socially influenced or
okay I see it how do I turn it off how
do I let it not influence me like do I
just like do the opposite of what I'm
afraid people criticize me for and I'm
like no no you're not trying to do the
opposite yeah of what people will of
what you're afraid you'll be CR like of
what you might be pushed into you're
trying to like
let the thought process complete without
that internal push like can you like
like not reverse the push but like
be unmoved by the push and can't are
these instructions even remotely helping
anyone I don't know I I think though
when those instructions even those the
words he's spoken and maybe you can add
more one practice daily
meaning in your daily communication so
it's daily practice of thinking without
influence from I would say find
prediction markets that matter to you
embed in the prediction markets that way
you find out if you are right or not
and you really there's Stakes
manifold product or even manifold
markets where the stakes are a bit lower
but the important thing is to like
get the the record
and you know I didn't build up skills
hereby prediction markets I built them
up via like well how did the film debate
resolve and
earn my own take on as to how it
resolved um and
yeah like
the the more you are able to notice
yourself not being dramatically wrong
but like having been a little off
your reasoning was a little off you
didn't get that quite right each of
those is a opportunity to make like a
small update so the more you can like
say oops softly routinely not as a big
deal the more chances you get to be like
I see where that reasoning went to stray
I see what how I should have reasoned
differently this is how you build up
skill over time